let me speak broadly about Rashida Talib
she is a vile disgusting horrible
anti-American communist awful
degenerate really just
I could go on but I was thinking this is
the number one show in late night and if
I said what I really believe about her
you you'd probably be canceled so when I
was in The Green Room I actually wrote
down what I think about her on a napkin
and I thought I would just hand it to
you
[Applause]
and if you read that aloud can I share
it if you read that aloud I will never
be on Fox again
how you doing people hello Internet I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's September 28
2022 we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube And blazetv subscribe tap the
notification Bell if you have not done
that already and I am seriously in the
mood to be here today I had a crazy
crazy week last week which culminated in
that appearance on the number one show
in late night the Greg Gutfeld program
Gutfeld exclamation point uh which was
on Friday and as Greg noted
during the show I was on the first
episode it was the same panel as the
first episode of the show which was less
than a year ago I think
um and I predicted that night on the
debut episode that he would be number
one in late night I think I said within
a year he ended up doing it in about
three months I I just love Greg and uh
and there's just good things happening
so oh I should also uh say a Happy New
Year to all you Hebrews out there
57.83 that's a long time uh that's a
whole lot of bagels and locks and my
week was nutty it was really a Nutty
week we traveled across America doing
all sorts of stuff the big one that
obviously uh you guys are psyched for
and the video is coming out I believe on
Sunday is a few days ago I was in Los
Angeles it was the one thing that could
drag me back to that crap hole uh and I
did Bill Maher's podcast I think we've
got an image of Bill and I that's after
a couple hours so it was is over two
hours it was supposedly the longest
podcast that he has done so far I'm told
that the clips and the full thing are
going to start going out this Sunday
we did it all we did it all I I'm just
gonna say I don't want to lead too much
I don't want to tease it too much or
anything but
we sat down we only had about a minute
before we actually sat down and the
cameras were rolling
um and we had to kind of feel each other
out like there was a little bit of
tension there he has to figure out what
to make of me I have to figure out what
to make him is he bringing me on to take
me out does he think I'm trying to take
him out but it just it was so organic it
was so good we hit everything from
Comedy there was a lot of sex talk I'm
just warning you up front he really
wanted to know about my sex life it was
that I'm not thrilled about that maybe
they could edit that part out but there
was just a lot it was just a lot of
everything there was a lot of tequila he
got me to smoke weed on I can't say he
got me to smoke weed about halfway
through I decided to jump in on the weed
but we did everything we did the
politics thing we talked Trump we talked
to Santas we talk liberals but it wasn't
all about politics we were really trying
to get to know each other he welcomed me
invited me on uh real time and that's
all I'll say about it for now but it was
it was just good it was good trust me
and you're going to want to watch the
full thing I'll leave it at that I've
probably said too much already but it's
an important piece of everything that
we're doing here that guys like Bill
Maher and I can sit down and and slog
through some of the nonsense because if
that conversation had ended after two
plus hours and we were just like ah that
was terrible you know we're not going to
do that again uh I think it would be
indicative of a bigger problem for
America but it was not like that it was
really really great and and Phoenix can
confirm I was I was stoned after how was
I in the car
what are you gonna do that's what weed
will do to you sorry uh anyway the other
big thing last week I think we've got
some video we've got some video of
Rumble Rumble went public it was awesome
all right
yeah
so that was me to the left there but
Rumble went public as you guys know I
started locals a couple years ago there
I am in Times Square biggest billboard
in Times Square pretty sweet it was it
was just a spectacular moment uh there's
me that's of course Dan bongino you
recognized Dan bongino uh Chris
pavlowski and the white shirt is the
rumble CEO and a soft Leb who is my
brother-in-law and the founder and CEO
the co-founder and CEO of locals so we
got to ring the bell it really was just
an incredible day and Free Speech has
gone public and that's what I'm so
thrilled about like there's a chance for
a company that has free speech and an
open internet
embedded in its mission statement uh now
public and that has not happened before
that certainly is not how it is with
Facebook or Google or anything else so
we have a lot of wins to share we're
going to be talking about some other
wins uh today because there's momentum
and that's really what the theme of
today's show is there is momentum
because the left is eating itself it's
exposing itself health and it's time for
us to realize no more second place how
about how about we start painting that
better Vision how about we start
executing that better vision and it's
happening all over the place this uh
this incredible upheaval in Italian
politics where now a formerly fascist
according to mainstream media is going
to be prime minister but of course she's
not really a far-right fascist so we're
going to get into that we're going to
get into a bunch more uh and of course
by the way I should have just mentioned
one other thing which I'll hit on a
little bit later uh there is a massive
hurricane heading this way so we're in
Miami at first it looked like it was
going to just go right into Southeast
Florida Miami area now it's going west
looks like Tampa Sarasota are going to
be hit the hardest
um but I'm going to do my best to help
as many people as possible and I said on
Twitter this morning I'll do some
fundraisers once we get on the other
side of this thing and uh and as I said
to the guys this morning it's like you
know everyone this weekend was out and
about I was at Home Depot at the
supermarket you know you can feel it on
the streets people are taking you know
making sure they have food and water and
all that stuff but there's like a
pleasantness here to all of it which is
in such stark contrast to where I was in
California which forget about covet when
everyone was evil and mean it was even
before that there was always like this
people are just not that Pleasant here
it was just like yeah there's a
hurricane to come in oh can I help you
get that rice and uh anyway it's uh
hopefully we don't lose power I guess
during the show that's the main point
all right let's talk about moist box and
then get to it uh do you guys know that
60 of U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day well
there's a better way and I want to tell
you about moink that's moo plus oink
moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door moink Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
Family Farm Does It Better the moink
difference is the difference you can
taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping Family Farms stay
financially independent too you can
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes to chicken breasts to pork
chops to salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel anytime my personal
favorite is their filet mignon Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and ring doorbell founder Jamie simenov
jumped at the chance to invest in moink
plus they'll guarantee you'll say oink
oink I'm just so happy I got mocked keep
American farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Ruben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time that is
m-o-i-n-k box.com reubenwickbox.com
Reuben okay
so we're going to talk about some wins
today and some momentum because as you
know it it's it's happening we can all
feel it things are looking good not to
say these people don't have tricks up
their sleeve and you know the Nordstrom
pipeline blew up and maybe they'll start
world war three right before the
election but putting that aside for a
moment uh there are good things
happening and when good things are
happening to freedom-loving people what
does the machine always do it's Slanders
and lies about them and then it tries to
cancel and silence them these are the
tactics that have been used over and
over that you guys have seen everyone is
now seeing it more and more people are
seeing it well interestingly Russell
Brandt now Russell Brand who of course
the comedian and an actor he's mostly a
lefty he's kind of going through a
little bit of a red pilling process
right now but he's mostly a lefty he's
had very uh big debates with public
debates with Candace Owens on all sorts
of stuff mostly a lefty well he is on
YouTube where he has about six million
subscribers uh today actually at noon
today his plan was to launch his Rumble
Channel His official Rumble Channel he's
going there exclusively and then what
happened to Russell Brand yesterday this
is so bizarre you're not going to
believe it better get in your seat uh
well he got a strike on his YouTube
channel and they forced him to delete a
video now I'm going to play a little
portion of Russell talking about at it
but what you have to understand is the
guy's been waking up politically that's
dangerous to the system and he's moving
off big Tech doubly dangerous to the
system so do you think he might have a
Target on his back here's Russell we
have been officially censored by YouTube
they took down one of our videos for
misinformation but why are big media
organizations not censored for
misinformation in the same way is it
because YouTube are part of the
mainstream media now earlier this month
we did a video about the changing
narratives around covid the pandemic and
covid treatments in which we cited
information on official government
websites which we misinterpreted I'll
have to be careful talking about it now
because I don't want to make the same
mistake that's had one of our videos
pulled down and an official warning
issue the good news is we're moving to
rumble all of our content is up on
Rumble first and we'll be streaming on
Rumble every day
okay so there's a couple things going on
here first off he is admitting that he
made a mistake related to some coveted
information he's saying we translated
the information uh incorrectly and he's
acknowledging that and then they took
the video down now this video has been
up already so the fact that YouTube Took
the video down yesterday the day before
he's about to make the move to rumble
tells you that there is something else
going on here right this is a little bit
more like a mafia hit now in his
explanation there he further goes on to
say that mainstream media
and now big Tech they work together so
you can share all kinds of
misinformation if you're on MSNBC or CNN
or if you're just a mainstream swamp
hack you can lie about everything you
can get everything wrong and nothing
will happen to you on any of these
platforms uh but you know if you're one
of us scary fascist right Wingers or
even you know buddy buddies with one of
them uh you're going to be taken out you
may remember former MSNBC host I don't
think she has the show anymore Rachel
Maddow this is less than a year ago
sharing misinformation about the coveted
vaccines now we know that the vaccines
work well enough that the virus stops
with every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
cannot use a vaccinated person as a host
to go get more people
yes it can use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get other people so
everything she said there was wrong
there was no evidence even when she said
that back less than a year ago there was
no evidence that she was completely
right about that there wasn't enough
time gone by with the vaccine that
whether to see whether it was going to
be a hundred percent safe or not the
reason I show you that video is that
video is all over YouTube that woman was
a host on MSNBC she stepped away from
the show but it wasn't because of that
they didn't fire her for sharing
misinformation like that but that video
again is all over the place so if you're
Russell Brand and now you're doing your
red pill thing or you're just not a
you're not a swamp creature anymore
right you're just I would say he's still
a lefty liberal something like that
we're going to have him on the show soon
and we'll talk about it
um
but he's waking up so if he makes a
mistake and acknowledges his mistake he
gets deleted and his channel gets a
strike and by the way if you get two
strikes on YouTube they disable your
ability to live stream so you can see
they're going after him this is very
similar by the way guys to when uh you
remember that remember that week about
four months ago where we spent a week
deciding whether Joe Rogan was a racist
and it just happened to be like two days
after he had a couple experts like Dr
Robert Malone on to talk about the covid
vaccines so you see what's getting on
what happens here the machine tries to
lie about you or cancel you but for some
reason Rachel Maddow in that video is
still up here is the elderly man
pretending to be president and uh this
is July of 2021 so just about a year ago
and he's apparently lying too the the
various shots that people are getting
Now cover that they're they're you're
okay you're not gonna you're not gonna
get coveted if you have these
vaccinations yeah oh you're not going to
get coveted if you get these
vaccinations that's funny because
actually this weekend the CEO of Pfizer
who is double that quadruple boosted or
something he got covered for the second
time in the last three months okay so it
was not true then it's not true now but
remember nobody runs around calling
Biden a misinformation Specialist or no
one's trying to take out Rachel Maddow
right so this is all about what your
ethos what your politics are and whether
you're actually getting something uh if
you're getting something approximate to
the truth then they will take you out
then we found this one this morning
because you know there's this hurricane
bearing down on Florida so someone found
this video this is Joe Biden the last
year talking about another hurricane and
what do you need to do more than
anything else when A hurricane's coming
should you get gas should you check if
your generator is working no should you
get food no forget about the food water
forget that there's something that is
key to the whole operation let me be
clear if you're in a state where a
hurricane is often strike like Florida
or the Gulf Coast or into Texas
a vital part of preparing for hurricane
season is to get vaccinated now
everything is more complicated if you're
not vaccinated in a hurricane or a
natural disaster hits
I think I just got brain damage while
watching that one even though I've seen
it 10 times it is I get it it's from
like a year ago from a different
hurricane but the level of stupidity
that we allowed to seep into the system
the fact that any of us pay any
attention to these people as if they're
experts or care about us or anything
else yes you better get vaccinated as
your house is being sent to oz in the
tornado you know you're hanging out with
the Tin Man and the Scarecrow who by the
way they're doing a remake of Wizard of
Oz and they're all going to be gay or
something that's that's another one
coming which I thought the Scarecrow was
gay or wasn't the Tin Man I thought they
were doing it the Tin Man in the
Scarecrow anyway
you get the point guys they lie about
everything but if you're on their side
and this is what Democrat privilege is
if you're on their side you can lie
about everything you can get everything
wrong you can you can attack your
opponent's motives and all those things
but if you're just somewhat awake you're
going to be destroyed and censored
that's what Russell is dealing with
right now however uh to get this to the
where we started today uh he's now
moving to rumble and he'll be live every
day at 12 Eastern right after this show
so that is pretty pretty sweet but let's
continue to expose The Maniacs because
there are maniacs and you know if I say
Maniac I'm either talking about a woman
of the view or Justin Trudeau we'll get
to them in just a second uh first let's
talk about real estate agents I trust
you guys know that buying or selling a
home is already one of the most
stressful things you can do and it can
be 10 times worse if you're not working
with the right agent our homes are
usually our biggest investment which is
a ton of responsibility and you need an
agent who takes that seriously that's
why I recommend real estate agents I
trust they work with only the best
agents in every Market they do their
homework they talk to every reagent
before inviting them to join their team
and here's a big one they only work with
full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents they make the intro
and then follow you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied satisfied the agents
they work with have long track records
and are the best sellers in their field
they're part of this audience they share
your values and they're almost anywhere
you want to go head over to real estate
agentsitrust.com today and provide them
with some basic info their team will
contact you to make an introduction to
the preferred agent in your town you
move to Florida you live happily ever
after even though there's a storm of
Bruin you can still move to Tampa or
Sarasota after this and it's all going
to be good okay so what else is going on
there are people who are being exposed
and they're being exposed left and right
thus
the people who are doing the exposing
must be banned and silenced and canceled
and the rest of it Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau who is a
blackface expert and a former he's a
wasn't he a theater teacher he's like a
theater cater saying he wears those
fancy socks
um well despite trying to destroy all
the freedom-loving people in his country
and taking out the truckers and having
bank accounts Frozen and the Draconian
lockdowns that he had finally nope no
more I guess apparently okay
every step of the way
we make decisions based on what experts
what doctors what public health
authorities recommend us to do and there
is the sense that these border measures
were no longer
um
effective or no longer justified in the
circumstance that we're in right now
you know how I often talk about how
Gavin Newsom is soulless and I really do
believe that we can get into a debate
about what the soul is and the Divine
spark that is in all of us I believe
that that spark my personal belief it
has something to do with the truth there
is a connection between your soul and
what you communicate to the world and
Truth Justin Trudeau like avenuesome is
soulless he cannot say a word of Truth
it is beyond his capabilities as a human
being this has nothing to do with
science it had nothing to do with
experts they didn't just magically two
days ago look at a new study and be like
okay we can open up the country and let
people who aren't vaxxed fly in and let
unvaxed fly out it's all complete
nonsense it's that they see the worm is
turning they see now that this might
cost them all their jobs and God willing
it will all of them every single one of
them including this guy this is Health
Minister Canadian Health Minister Jean
Yvette oh I believe I pronounced that
right announcing the end of vaccine
passports testing masking and a bunch of
other stuff we are announcing that the
government of Canada will not renew the
order in council that expires on
September the 30th and will therefore
remove all covid-19 border requirements
for all travelers entering Canada
this includes the removal of all federal
testing quarantine and isolation
requirements as well as the mandatory
submission of health information in a
rifcon
isn't this rather extraordinary these
people who forced people out of their
jobs and got rid of doctors and nurses
and looked into truckers bank accounts
and destroyed the economy of Canada and
have still have just wrecked what
Toronto once was and what some of the
major cities Montreal once were suddenly
they're going by golly let's not do any
of that stuff let's not force the
vaccines let's not uh force people to be
locked in their houses and anything jeez
G G willikers I can't believe it it's
it's we're just going to flip on
everything we've done now are they
flipping on everything they've done
because they've seen the light
because they really realized they were
wrong in which case they would all
actually they'd all resign in shame and
never be seen from again but that
certainly ain't what Justin Trudeau is
going to do is it that that they've
realized they were wrong or could they
see the writing on the wall could
something be happening across the world
right now uh that is going to reverse
all of this well I think it's the latter
and we got some major major news out of
Italy over the weekend over the last
couple days uh here's a quote from the
daily wire Georgia Maloney claimed
Victory early Monday morning and is
projected to win a battle to become
Italy's first female prime minister
leading her conservative party Brothers
of Italy in the country's national
elections okay now first off she's a
woman
she's a woman I think she uses women
pronouns she's chick boobs the whole
thing uh now generally speaking the
lefties and the progressives and you
know all these people they love women so
you'd think they'd be very excited about
this but no no no she's scary she's a
conservative uh we've got two clips of
Maloney uh giving a speech about why she
ran what she believes in and what she
wants to do to Italy this first one is
absolutely phenomenal foreign
foreign
perfect
oh I love it it's just so good she's the
telling the truth you know what I'm not
saying guys you get it you get it so
here is a western democracy now a lot of
this stuff has been happening in some of
the Eastern countries in Europe Eastern
European countries but here's a Western
European democracy that has had enough
of the wokeness it has had enough of
collectivism it has had enough of people
being defined by their gender or their
other immutable characteristics it it's
had enough of you saying that your kids
are born boys but they're actually girls
The Assault on religion The Assault on
all of our institutions this is a
phenomenal speech so of course everyone
in the western media is calling her a
fascist and and even worse than that uh
here are uh here's a little video of her
being called a fascist because you know
she believes in the individual which I
thought was the basis of Western
Civilization voters in Italy tomorrow
appear Poise to make a hard right turn
the woman expected to become Prime
Minister leads a party with roots in
neo-fascism the Hallmarks of Italian
fascism like this motto
God Fatherland and family they far-right
political party whose roots go back to
post World War II neo-fascists far-right
political party whose roots go back to
post-world War II neo-fascists roots in
Italy's post-war fascist movements roots
in Italy's 20th century neo-fascist
movement Milani herself uh was a a
hardcore neo-fascist militant stunning
because of Italy's disastrous history
the last time a hard-right party Rose to
power the most far-right government in
that country since Mussolini most
right-wing government since Mussolini
since Mussolini okay so you guys get the
game right we've we've looked past we've
moved the curtain and we're looking past
and it's not the all-powerful laws it's
just some washed up old dude back there
in that game is that they try to scare
the hell of hell out of you until you
pull that curtain back she's far right
she's a fascist blah blah blah well I
listened to all the speeches I did a
little research research on her I've
talked to a couple people what what
would that mean that she's a far-right
fascist so she's a far right address so
she hates immigrants or something like
that no she actually wants borders we
had an orange man who wanted borders and
they said he was a fascist remember that
um what what is a fascist well fascist
of course is someone who wants corporate
power to be completely aligned with
political power but that's the reverse
of what she was saying in that speech
what she was saying in that speech is
it's up to you it's your life you
shouldn't become just the ultimate
consumer of all of the things that the
monster that the big government
corporate monster wants you to be right
uh the what is fascism it wields the
state's political power on all private
and public institutions right that's
what it does she's trying to separate
those things but the media is showing
you the cards and the cards are she is
far right fashion they never tell you
what actually that means it just sounds
scary enough my God Mussolini Hitler
somebody do something
well this is just a spectacular
spectacular moment uh one of her
political main political Rivals he's
from a lefty party in Italy his name is
Mateo renzi well he was asked if she's
actually a fascist and I don't think CNN
liked the answer but
um personally Frankly Speaking I was
against
Georgia Maloney so I'm not the best
friend that we grew up together in
politics but we were we we are and will
be arrival always at the same time I
think
that is not a danger for Italian
democracy she is my rival I I'm rival we
will continue to fight each other but
the ideas are now there is a risk of the
fascism in Italy is absolutely a fake
news she won election particularly
because populism a lot of times won in
Italy
sorry Mateo you ain't getting on CNN
again he is former prime minister by the
way so this is not just some like little
cabinet minister somewhere in Italy and
as he said we grew up in politics
together I disagree with her on the
fundamental issues but she's not an
extremist and she certainly isn't a
fascist but the media has no problem
lying to you about everything and
everyone if they don't bow to the
narrative so why are they freaking out
about her well we showed you a little
bit of it before but she continued
defending nationalism defending
individual freedom and the right for
Italians to set what the Italian agenda
is going to be like
foreign
foreign
quoting Chester tip defending truth
that's all it is truth we are all
individuals we are all unique we can
come together to create a community and
a country and a government to to protect
our rights and apparently Italy has had
enough but the mainstream media this is
man it's crazy because it shouldn't be
this way and it's not supposed to be
this way and it doesn't have to be this
way but this is what they do so now I
want to bring this back uh to America
for just a moment because as I mentioned
up top and as all of you watching no
there is a massive massive hurricane
bearing down on Florida right now and it
is very very obvious that there is
nothing that the mainstream media that
the corporate press would like more than
for this hurricane to cause a massive
disaster in Florida I'm talking
blackouts and deaths and all that I
really believe that I'm not being
hyperbolic when I say it they would love
for this hurricane to demolish Florida
that because you already got it yes
because it would take out Ron DeSantis
or it would at least damage Ron DeSantis
the santis and the entire apparatus of
Florida
have been dealing with this thing
incredibly well incredibly well so he
gave five press conferences yesterday
five press conferences his last one was
at 11 PM last night
um about what's going on here how to be
prepared what areas are going to be the
worst hit what you can do the whole
stuff I've never seen a more uh
efficient and and clear and clean
explanation of what to do in a natural
emergency but of course the media really
really wants to get them FEMA
administrator Chris Paul said today that
she acknowledged concerns that Florida
as it was said lacks response to this
storm so far and that will give me a
break that is nonsense stop politicizing
okay stop it we declared a state of
emergency when this thing wasn't even
formed we've had people in here you've
had counties doing uh they've done a lot
of hard work and and honestly you're
trying to attack me I get but like
you're attacking these other people
who've worked very hard and so so that
just totally false I don't think we've
ever certainly since I've been Governor
declared a state emergency this early we
made sure that we were very inclusive
with it we said that there was a lot of
uncertainty and and we've worked to make
sure the preparations that have been
done and all the the stuff you talk to
the people at the counties when they've
needed something stuff gets there very
quickly because of what Kevin and his
team have done
perfect answer right perfect answer they
want to get him the media wants to get
him trust me Politico MSNBC Washington
most they already have the Articles
written they are they are written
already and These Guys these loser
alcoholic pathetic pandering buffoon
journalists okay air quote journalist
they are waiting to click publish so
that they can get what they want which
is the destruction of Rhonda said this
it ain't gonna happen it ain't gonna
happen and everyone here in Florida is
doing the best that they can and coming
together and on top of everything else
whether it was Gavin Newsom in
California or Ron DeSantis here in
Florida the governor cannot control the
weather and the governor cannot keep
everyone safe all the time what he can
do is or he or she can do is do the best
they can to create a functioning
apparatus so the state is protected to
the best ability possible so just a
perfect absolutely perfect answer by
this answers and you can see how I'm
linking that uh to the Italian Prime
Minister because it's like they're gonna
lie about her they're going to lie about
him they're going to lie about Russell
Brand they're going to lie about you and
that's what we are fighting so how
can we expose them even further well one
way is to mock them and show their
nonsensical racist
diatribes for themselves uh and now we
got the we got the warning yeah there we
go sorry uh yeah we got something from
The View here's Sonny Austin and for
Anna one of my issues has always been I
don't understand how a Latina woman
right who even left them from Nicaragua
could be part of a of a party because
when I became when I came to this
country when I came to this country the
Republican party was the party that
stood up against communism and that is
something that is ingrained in me in the
same way that being a Catholic isn't
greater than you but listen when Pope
Benedict who was part of parcel of
covering up the pedophilia scandal in
the church was Pope you still stayed in
the Catholic Church you know because
there's more to it I actually stopped
going to church but wait that is nice
listen all of this has nothing to do
with the question
don't even ask what the question was it
doesn't even matter honestly but do you
see what they do Sonny Hassan who is a
he she is a racist and an idiot I mean
she is truly the worst person on on
network television there's so many of
them but Sunny really is number one and
she's like racing away with it you know
what I mean there used to be horse races
like is it stelter is it Don Lemon is it
you know but Sunny is just bam she's
lapping these people in the most bigoted
[ __ ] on on television
um to turn to a Latino woman and say you
are not in command of your mind you you
must vote the way that I want you to
vote in and of itself is racist if you
think that all black people must vote a
certain way or all gay people must vote
a certain way and they must think the
way you think they must think you are
the racist you are the bigot that is the
summation of what the left has at the
moment and it's also interesting because
uh Anna Navarro she I don't know that
she considers herself a republican
anymore I mean basically she's a
progressive right so it's all lefties on
that show and then they've got Alison
farra this fake conservative something
right but she her main gig what got her
popular and what put her on The View was
that she worked for Marco Rubio Marco
Rubio whose parents came from Cuba and
Marco's been on the show and he's
described the the scene growing up of
his parents working in kitchens praying
that they could get a little bit of a
better life from what they fled and now
their son is a freaking Senator and
former presidential candidate they know
what they fled and it's interesting she
also says well I'm a republican because
Republicans were against communism
Democrats basically are communists at
this point I I think you could argue I
don't wanna I don't want to make a big
deal about it but I think you could
argue the Democrats are basically
fascist at this point I don't want to
play their game but they love the
combination of Corporation and political
power oh you get jabbed because the
government told the corporation to do it
right that's anti-individual all right I
won't play their games to the extent
that they play them but watching them
eat themselves alive is just spectacular
we've got a little more from The View
can you put the warning up again we must
warn the people uh because Karin
Jean-Pierre the black lesbian who is the
press secretary for the elderly man
pretending to be president she went on
and uh she you know she's just well
watched it's the last time you were on
with us you were pretty unequivocal that
President Biden was running again in
2024 because I think I asked you that
question but over the weekend he said
something that I haven't heard him say
he said it was much too early to make
the decision decision on whether he will
run opening up the door in our view to
my view to potentially not seeking
another term it's almost unheard of of
course for a sitting president to waver
on running right so were you surprised
that he said that the change of tone
well I I will say this and I think he
followed up and said that he intends to
run and that's basically been the place
that he has been and I have said that he
has said that the vice president has
said that he intends to run
um you know and look I think for this
president for this Administration it is
so important to focus at what to focus
on what's at hand and that's where our
head is at it's just such disingenuous
public relations nonsense right like the
way she speaks the way her inflection
and her tone and her where she looks
down and all these things it's so not
real and authentic Joe Biden is not
running again they are going to eat him
and destroy him if his brain doesn't
explode before the next election it is
not going to happen but it but as I've
said many times they're all in it in on
it there's a reason Kamala says she's
going to support Joe and Gabe heat says
it and Corrine jump here because it's
all they've got all they've got is that
they've sucked up to the system and the
system gave them jobs that they don't
deserve so you got to keep sucking it's
a lot of sucking your jaw is freaking
tired at the end of the day it's true it
really is true but this is just
beautiful so now uh Jen saki now you
remember Jen saki uh she was the former
White House Press Secretary the woman
could not say anything true of her life
depended on it uh well she's even now
she is what happens to her she leaves
the White House and then what do you do
you get a job she's an NBC News analyst
and she has a show I think coming out on
MSNBC but think about how fraudulent the
entire they do it right in front of our
faces you are a paid public relations
liar for an Administration that's what
your job is to do and then you get a job
analyzing the news and we're supposed to
take any of this seriously you clowns
you ridiculous abject clowns well here
she is completely contradicting Karen
Jean-Pierre they also know that crime is
a huge vulnerability for Democrats I
would say one of the biggest
vulnerabilities says that crime is a
huge vulnerability for Democrats why
would you say that so you know
um again I can't do electoral politics
from here as you know but I I kind of I
don't agree with your character
organization of what she actually said
I mean she literally said it's a huge
liability for Democrats now what's funny
is when jensaki was standing behind that
Podium only months ago she would have
never acknowledged that crime is a
problem for Democrats right she would
try to confuse you we've played many
videos where they tried to make it sound
like Republicans were defunding the
police and actually democrat-run cities
aren't uh you know drowning in crime
could we get the number Daphne could we
get the how many people were shot in
Chicago this past weekend can I get a
death and shooting number please uh this
is what's happening across Democrat
cities we all know it the average person
knows it we spent time we spent about 48
hours in New York City and it it's a
dump it is a dump I loved New York City
growing up my great-grandparents lived
there my grandma lived there I lived in
New York City from 2000 to 2013. I was
there during 9 11. I absolutely loved
New York City if you can make it there
you can make it anywhere
um I gave I gave Connor the full
Seinfeld tour of the Upper West Side
showing off all the restaurants and
everything like I love New York City or
Love New York City it's a dump now it
smells like weed Everywhere You Don't
See business people that's what was
shocking we were in Midtown we we
wandered around like you don't see
people wearing suits like doing business
anymore you just see a lot of people in
hoodies and everyone smells like weed
and I'm not even against weed at some
level or certainly at a personal level
but everything smells like weed it's
dirty the you can sense like there's
that that if you just got punched in the
face on the street that nobody would
care that it just wouldn't matter and
all that stuff 38 people were shot in
Chicago uh this past weekend seven dead
uh we're not going to hear any of their
names because you can guess the color of
the skin of the shooters and the color
of the skin of the victims doesn't fit
the equation so we can't talk about that
but the point is that saki she goes from
being a liar at the White House then she
just makes more money to be a liar and a
quote analyst so if you've got a friend
that's it that watches NBC news or MSNBC
for news you got to say to them you got
to grab them you got to grab them by the
head and you gotta you gotta smack them
and you gotta smack them again and go
what are you doing you're getting your
news from someone who is has told you
what they are they are an activist they
are they she she is a Democrat right
that's okay you could be a there's
Republican versions of all of this too
right the swamp is what the swamp is I'm
just talking about the girl that's doing
it now the idea that she could analyze
uh news for you the same person who's
been lying about the news that like she
was the chief liar for the last year and
now she's a news analyst just absolutely
incredible but let's go back to the view
can you throw up the warning one more
time I think I think we only need it one
more time today uh because
Joy Baylor
George I should call her joyless joyless
Behar uh she has a winning ticket she
thinks the Democrats can do it she's
very very excited then I think
Gavin Newsom has a chance Gavin Newsom
and Stacey Abrams what a ticket that
would be oh pretty good
what are these seals clapping about do
they literally throw small fish into the
audience so that they will clap and
hopefully get fish in their mouth oh my
God Joy like is that what they're doing
is that what they're I've been to the to
the audience of the view they don't even
give you water I don't even it's really
it's pretty terrible
um shout out to my buddy Tom who I think
maybe still is the warm-up comic
although I probably shouldn't have said
that because now he's going to get fired
anyway Tom if you need a job let me know
um you guys get the point here you guys
get the point these people are crazy
you're actually crazy Joy Maher you
think Gavin Newsom who destroyed
California
with Stacy Abrams who has never
accomplished anything other than
spending four hours at the um
Golden Corral what's a what's a Golden
Corral is that a buffet yeah she closed
down at Golden Corral in Atlanta I'm
pretty sure that's it
no the actually the one thing that I
know for sure she has accomplished is
that she claimed that the Georgia
elections were stolen from her that's
the only thing so this is what this is
what uh Joy Behar wants she wants Gavin
Newsom a man who destroyed California
and a woman who is only known for her
situation at the buffet and her uh you
know questioning election results she
wants them that's the dream ticket oh my
God everybody uploads and it's just
great well you know what Gavin Newsom
who obviously is going to run and who's
actively trying to take out uh Joe Biden
uh this weekend uh well they asked him
he was doing a talk and someone asked
him well why is everyone leaving Cali if
you're such a great dude and listen to
this pure abject horse poop lie are more
people leaving California for Texas
we're leaving Texas for California we
lost about 182 000 folks in the last but
how do you explain that against the
backdrop of those very remarkable
statistics you just cited many factors
and there's been two deep analysis that
drives the number one factor the most
the vast majority at most the entire
amount impacted because of the Visa
policies in the Trump Administration
this whole damn border debate is made up
it's made up
where's Congress where the hell are they
having done their job
he's soulless it's the only way to
describe him the the light that is in
all of us that has something to do with
truth has been extinguished and he is an
evil reptilian monster so now first off
360
000 people left California last year we
just checked while he was talking 360
000. so he lied about the number and
then he completely lies about why
it had something to do with the Trump
Visa program uh Connor when you were
when we were packing up and everything
did anything to do with the Trump Visa
program Phoenix Trump Daphne did you
know about the Trump Visa
yeah we left because Los Angeles had
turned into a dystopian nightmare of
crime and lockdowns and drugs and just
the worst of what a society could be
well I can't say the worst because San
Francisco is worse and that is what his
job was he was the mayor of San
Francisco before Los Angeles people fled
California and are fleeing California in
droves because of high taxes
mismanagement fires uh electrical
outages you are a horrible horrible
person Gavin Newsom and you've always
been a horrible person here's Gavin
Newsom I like this one well done today
Phoenix here's Gavin Newsom back in 2008
promising to end homelessness in 10
years we believe fundamentally that food
solves hunger that shelters soft sleep
and that housing solves homelessness and
if we're going to solve the problem of
those that are out on the streets that
we Define as homeless we better solve
the housing a problem if we're going to
have an impact and that's why we
established this framework what we call
a 10-year plan to end chronic homeless
in San Francisco okay not only did he
not do that he actually did the reverse
he destroyed San Francisco don't forget
it know it share it with your
brainwashed friends like Joy Behar I
love the line food solves hunger it's so
brilliant food solves hunger what are we
having for lunch today by the way should
we do a little Chick-fil-A maybe we'll
discuss uh food sells over housing
solves homelessness
meaningless dribble which makes him the
perfect Democrat actually that's not yes
food at some level what if the Democrats
are very very good at at this level
right base level they can get you say
something that makes sense food solves
hunger and then they go oh my God food
sunsoft hunger when I'm hungry I have
food I have a Snickers bar and then I
don't want to punch somebody okay that's
that is sort of right and housing solves
homelessness well I suppose if you
didn't have a house and you were
homeless and then they gave gave you a
house you wouldn't be homeless so that
sort of works at that level all you have
to do is think about it for a half a
second more and realize that these are
just meaningless dribble slogans are you
going to endlessly give people food and
would that solve the food shortage
problem uh are you going to endlessly
give people housing or is it possible
that these people have deep
psychological problems often that they
have massive drug addiction problems
that you haven't created the conditions
for them to get good high-paying jobs so
that more bill or you have over
regulation of buildings so that the
contractors who want to come in and
build better houses and innovate don't
want to even come to your city he is a
liar he has been wrong at absolutely
everything forever although miraculously
this weekend he did say one thing that
kind of made sense these guys are
ruthless on the other side where are we
where are we organizing bottom up a
compelling alternative there where are
we going on the offense every single day
they're winning right now the Democratic
party has to assert itself much more
aggressively
well he was right that we're winning and
that's why he's freaking out he's got
absolutely nothing but again don't count
your chickens till they hatch okay these
people have things up their sleeve
whether it's starting a freaking nuclear
war with Ukraine or God knows what covid
7 monkey pox 9 don't forget it but but
he just he's nothing he is nothing but a
reptile in a suit so what's happening
and why are they losing well you know
what's happening good decent people
finally I know you guys watching this
show you woke up either alongside of me
or maybe you were ahead of me maybe
you're on your way but a lot of people
are waking up and there was an article
in the New York Post a day or two ago
that we've got some info from about the
liberals who were waking up you might
recognize that guy in the middle they
got a nice shot of me in front of those
two other uh famously disaffected people
pretty sweet this is this is very pat
yourself on the back Dave but it's an
interesting article that I was uh I was
interviewed for and I want to read a
little bit about about the shift that is
happening politically right now here we
go from the New York Post registered
Democrats are sick of the radical left
and some are switching sides the social
justice obsessed Ultra Progressive
increasingly illiberal left is even
alienating liberal celebrities once
FedEd as a progressive darling Tesla CEO
Elon Musk tweeted in May that he can no
longer support the Democrats in the past
I voted Democrat because they were
mostly the kindness party he wrote but
they have become the party of division
and hate so I can no longer support them
and will vote Republican in June he
followed through on that Promise by
voting for Texas Republican Myra Flores
in a special House of Representatives
election Flora is won in a massive upset
becoming the country's first
mexican-american-born U.S congresswoman
YouTube podcaster Dave Rubin married
Tapper Dave Rubin resigned his post in
2015 at The Young Turks popular
left-wing News Channel after his own
political Awakening he now dubs himself
the why I left the left guy in a YouTube
video that is going garnered more than
15 million views he made his position
clear today's progressivism has become a
faux moral movement hurling charges of
racism bigotry xenophobia xenophobia
homophobia islamophobia and a slew of
other meaningless buzzwords that anyone
they disagree with the Battle of ideas
has been replaced by a battle of
feelings and outrage has replaced
honesty
diversity Reigns Supreme unless it's
that pesky diversity of thought this
isn't a recipe for a free Society it's a
recipe for authoritarianism in November
last year HBO host Bill Maher echoed the
same thoughts when he told Chris Cuomo
on CNN that the Democratic party was
toxic because it had become the party of
no common sense he said he expected the
Democrats to get thumped in the midterm
elections this year he might just be
right according to an Associated Press
report in June more than one million
voters in 43 states have left the
Democrat Party for the Republican Party
especially in the suburbs where swing
voters can sway election results okay so
it's nice that I got a little ink there
okay but that's not why I'm reading it
to you as I've said to you guys before
there is only a small sliver of people
in the United States who you really can
move at this point right so you're never
going to move let's say the Trump the
hardcore Trump base or republican base
they're never going to become Democrats
and be like you know what Democrats and
the social justice Warriors and Joe
Biden are in I'm moving there the let's
say the real hardcore base of the
Democrats they're never going to somehow
move and be like yes I'm voting for
Trump or even DeSantis DeSantis who
they're gonna paint as even worse than
Trump as you know so who can be moved
well there are a sliver of people
a sliver of people who are somewhat sort
of Centrist sane people who over the
last couple years because of covid have
woke up to what big government and big
Tech are doing to all of us and if you
are concerned about constant censorship
if you are concerned about people that
want to lock you in your house and force
you to be injected with things and have
policies that stop business from coming
into your neighborhood and increase
homelessness and increase violence and
all of those things if you're concerned
about any of that then you might just be
moved to the Republican position a
little bit as I always say it does not
mean that they're great but you cannot
be a Democrat you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
so there is this slew of people and in
this article they're including people
like me let's say and Milan and Bill
Maher as people that are voicing what's
going on here a million Democrats
from a year ago are now registered
Republicans here in Florida there's now
a around a 300 000 surplus of
Republicans to Democrats when DeSantis
took over there was a deficit about 50
000. people are waking up and the reason
I'm always hitting on this is that's the
group of people who might just decide
the fate of Western Civilization or at
least the fate of the United States of
America because those are the people who
could be like you know what
boy I I disagree with Republicans on on
certain stuff but they aren't trying to
destroy everybody and they do seem to
like America and there does seem to be
some chance that the family will still
exist and the individual will still
exist and reality will still exist kind
of like uh the Italian Prime Minister
was saying and that I think is sort of
where we are at at the moment so we are
winning right now we are winning but
it's still going to take a hell of a lot
of work and you never want to get too
overconfident overconfident but we have
to keep the momentum going so you must
be public I think I think all of if
you're watching the show you got to get
a little more Brave right now you got to
get a little more Brave and start
telling people what you think or or at
least putting it into practice in your
own life whatever that means uh and
stand not only up for what you believe
but also tell people what you're against
kind of like Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis I reject socialism outright I
reject
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
Marxism leninism communism any of these
isms that have come out of of a
political theory that basically uh
denies the worth of each and every
individual denies people's aspirations
uh to reach for the stars uh denies the
fact that we have inherent god-given
rights
I'd give it right individual rights
caring about the family belief in
reality whether it's in Italy or right
here in Florida there is a winning
message here and it's and it's very
obviously a winning message and that's
why they're censoring that's why they're
censoring that's why they're canceling
because that's all they got because if
you're Gavin Newsom or you're a tech CEO
a big Tech CEO who's been running all
this nonsense what can you what can you
fall back on what are your policies that
work is it that high taxation really
works is it that big government programs
really work is it that locking people in
their home really works so more and more
people are seeing it and since they
don't have good arguments well they can
call us fascists and they can call us
bigots and then they can also delete all
their accounts and everything else so
that's what we gotta fight but I have
nothing better to do than save the world
do you uh let's stick around for a cold
close but I got a couple comments
excuse me from the Reuben report locals
Community lucky says best conspiracy
theory I've seen is that the elites
created the hurricane with their weather
machine to hurt the freest place on
Earth I could almost buy that because
they'd love to see Florida destroyed
except these people are so incompetent
that a bunch of social justice Warriors
trying to build a weather machine sort
of seems hilarious although that does
remind me of the episode of GI Joe
cartoon around 1985 when Cobra built a
weather machine and I don't have to tell
you how that ended Jeannie says the
right finally the right finally started
shouting loud enough to be heard over
the sycophants whispering in their ears
yes I love that and that's the
importance of speaking up too many of us
we just let it all happen and I include
myself in that even we all just it was
happening we were calling it out we
didn't know what to do but time is up
man it is time to push back and alert
your friends and family that are not
there yet to know what reality is
because man I'm telling you this
censorship and the crazy news is going
to ramp up over the next two months like
never before month and a half let's say
till the election it's going to be
bananas and they will censor and they
will algorithmically trick and they will
Shadow band and all of those things I
hope that's why you're watching at
rumble.com Ruben report and you've
joined us at reubenreport.locals.com
which is free to join and if you want to
play along then you can throw in a
couple bucks if you want because that
way we can directly communicate with you
because what they're doing to Russell
what they're doing to anyone that
they've canceled what they tried to do
to Rogan it it ain't gonna stop because
it's all they got Stephen says I'm not
sure if Justin Trudeau shares the same
reality as the rest of the country yeah
it's like what is he on I mean the guy's
got to be on something on top of
everything else like just awful these
people just awful but if you think I'm
being too hard on these people if you
think I'm missing something if you think
Evan Newsom and Justin Trudeau and these
other people are good let us know in the
comments and maybe I'll address it
because you know maybe I'm wrong I don't
think so but maybe anyway if you're here
in the Free State of Florida take care
of yourself get some food get some water
uh make sure that the roof's on the on
the house and all that good stuff and uh
for everyone else have a great day uh
Russell Brand is up on Rumble at noon
today my full interview with Tim Scott
senator from South Carolina is up right
now uh and we got a great cold close for
you I love this one all right see you
tomorrow everybody
[Music]
at some point in time they have to move
we don't have the services to take care
of safety immigrants
[Music]
state of Massachusetts is stepping in
mobilizing the National Guard
they got rid of them within 44 hours
[Music]